alisandra Corsi going to be telling us
about gravitational wave astronomy with
advanced LIGO
which I could think if we took a bet
last year about this time as to when we
would have a field most people would
have said two years from now three years
from now so we got started a little bit
early and that's great and so we should
hear a few things I imagine about last
year and prospects for the future all
right so thanks very much for having me
here I wanted to thank particularly you
Peter and Josh for inviting me and yes
I'll start talking a bit about
gravitational waves and the first part
of my talk is really geared toward an
expert so apologize for the experts in
the room but I'd like to sort of make
sure that my talker reaches a little bit
of a broader audience and I am speaking
on behalf of the LIGO and video
collaborations the LIGO collaboration in
particular includes many institution my
institution is Texas Tech is over there
so what this means is you can think of
all the good things I'm gonna say or on
behalf of the LLC the bad ones are just
my personal ones so here's a little bit
of an overview I'd like to very briefly
again just for a non-expert just remind
ourselves what gravitational waves are
because this is indeed a new way of
doing astronomy given that we've only
reached detection in the last couple of
years and I would like to speak a little
bit about the type of signals that like
in Virgo have detected so far
particularly black holes the pH there
and the remarkable event dubbed GW 1708
17 corridor number 17 2017 that was the
first binary neutron star murdered like
a Virgo detected and then here is where
the real time decisions come in I'm
gonna be talking a little bit about Sky
localization and follow-up of the
signification or wave triggers in the
electromagnet
ban which links to what has been
discussed but in part already and to
what Muncie after me is gonna discuss is
this is not just you know deciding what
what constituents are confident
detection on the Vigo Vigo end but then
is spreading that alert around so that
lots of astronomers around the world can
make their own decisions about whether
to follow or not which part of the sky
to select and so on and then I'm going
to comment
just a bit about future prospects so
gravitational waves again and this is a
new type of way I'd like to think about
it of doing astronomy astronomy and the
key thing is that we're looking at
gravity in a slightly different way
compared to how Newton conceived it so
we're looking at really accelerating
massive objects which are the sources of
gravitational waves and you can think
about massive objects accelerating as
curving space times and as they
accelerate toward each other that
curvature changes and so you need to
sort of transport that message about the
time change in curvature across the
universe the message startles at the
speed of light in the form of
gravitational waves so visually you can
think about this as ripples in the
fabric of space-time which is usually
what you would a typical description
that you would hear about them so
there's some kind of information that
needs to travel further universe about
the fact that two masses might be
changing positions which wasn't really
Newton's formulation of gravity there
you would instantaneously know what the
positions of the masses are so those
ripples come in two polarization the
plus in the cross what does all this
mean you can imagine a circle of free
particles over there and a gravitational
wave that would be traveling orthogonal
to the screen here plus polarized would
cause as the wave goes through this type
of pattern so first squish
the distance between those three
particles in that direction and then it
will elongate it and so on the cross
polarization you can think about it as
the same one but rotated 45 degrees with
respect to the plus all we care about
however in this talk going forward is
that the amplitude that I'm indicating
as an H here of the gravitational wave
is proportional to the fraction of
kinetic energy that goes into some sort
of asymmetric distribution scales
inversely with the distance of the
object and then the Keen thing is that
this constant big G or recei to the
force the speed of light is really
really tiny so the problem of this is
that in order to detect gravitational
waves you need to really be looking at
large masses accelerating rather
abruptly and for that the type of masses
that we need that you're really looking
into astronomical objects so the
distances are pretty far away this
amplitude of the wave you can gives you
the order of displacement okay so the
effect is the strain changing of the
relative distance between a distribution
of free masses so that's what I mean by
Delta L and if you imagine a certain
astronomical source giving you a certain
age or you want to measure is that Delta
L so you want to really make the scale
of your detector pretty large in order
for that number up here to not be
unmeasurable so this is why
gravitational wave detectors here based
on earth are pretty large detectors this
is a viewer logical livingstone l-shaped
detectors this arm doesn't fit in the
picture both arms are 4 kilometers long
and it's twin if you like experimental
LIGO Hanford also 4 kilometers also this
arm doesn't fit in the picture but there
is also a similar experiment in Italy
called very good at 3 kilometers long
arms but what you're dealing with is
really large elves in that equation in
order to make sure there's a measurable
effect when you try were in trying to
catch these waves as I said in order to
find suitable sources you need to be
looking at astronomical sources like a
Paris machine neutron stars 1.4 times
the mass of our Sun and if you go into
calculating what could be the H that H
or Delta L over L the amplitude of the
gravitational waves wave at a sort of
kind of near distance you could think of
measuring that's order of 10 to the
minus 21 so 10 to the minus 21 is a
small number with a lot of zeroes up
front and so what this means is that if
you're trying to measure that
displacement Delta L over a range of 4
kilometers like the arm lengths of those
detectors that I showed you you're
trying to measure something which is
order of 10 to the minus 19 meters or a
lamb for 4 kilometers so that is pretty
impressive and that is why you're
reaching this point where we can
actually directly detect gravitational
waves here on earth took quite a bit
what a long time so just to remind you
was mulish 10 to the minus 18 I'm
putting a meter here I'm scaling it and
the key messages we're looking at stuff
which is a thousand times smaller than
the scale of the nuclear diameter so
again and this are really kind of
impressive measurements were going after
now how do you actually achieve that
those detectors are l-shaped because you
can think about them in really
simplistic terms as Marshall
interferometers so what you're trying to
do is you're firing a laser that laser
goes through the beam splitter so it's
beam gets split into different one that
goes along orthogonal arms in that
detector those little things here
represent mirrors so the light goes
through one arm it gets reflected back
it goes back to the beam splitter same
thing in the other arm and the two
signals they recombine each other
you tend to keep the interferometer what
we call is in the
our fringe so the interference patterns
such that its destructive at the output
detector in order to have highest
sensitivity to any change to that so you
can imagine your gravitational wave
passing by it displaces that mirror
okay maybe compresses that arm and
stretches a little bit the other one so
now the interference patterns that we
were out put detector changes you
measure light all of a sudden you're not
on the dark fringe anymore so you see a
power variation and that's what's
actually detected by timing these
photons so here's how advanced LIGO if
you like came to be so the construction
started in 1994 2002 and initial LIGO
which did not yield any detections was
operational between 2000 to 2007 and I'd
like to think about this because 2007
was the year of my PhD so when I was
graduating the last chapter of my thesis
had actually some of the first data that
were coming from between the doctor
Virgo which were not even or science
science quality data yet but then there
were some minor upgrades done to initial
I go around 2009 2010 again no detection
there these years are remembered them as
pestering both Peter here and Josh for
helping me out trying to do the first
attempt into following up in the optical
triggers which at the time were just
noise from enhance LIGO and then again
the big the big change happens after the
advanced LIGO installation so the first
observing run of LIGO in its advanced
configuration was between September 2015
and January 2016 and this is where this
run is usually referred to as o1
observing run one and this is where the
first detection arrived last November
between November 2016 and August 2017
after some other improvements the
detector went through their second
observing run and the key thing here was
the Virgo was able to join also in with
improve the sensitivity so this was the
first run where at least toward the end
of it three detectors were operating
we're looking forward to the third
observing run which should start roughly
in November this year a question about
enhanced like oh yes the given what you
now know about the first handful of
detections made do you think there was
anything in that data or was it truly
just noise yeah it's not surprising that
we didn't detect anything before yeah
and especially initial LIGO even was you
know more of a proof of concept and it
was understood that there should have
been more development in sensitivity
before anything could yes true even of
the binary neutron star merger that that
would not have had enough signal so the
binary neutron star merger was 40 mega
parsec distance and I think the reach of
the enhanced should I think it was order
of 20 if I'm not mistaken yes okay so
this is the path and here's what it all
means now this u-shaped plot is
something that we like to use in order
to show you how sensitive our
gravitational wave detector is it has
frequency on the x-axis and string noise
amplitude funky objects with dimensions
of square root of Earth's and the y axis
so what we're doing here is we're taking
the power spectral density of the noise
plotting its square root that's where
that square root of Earth's comes in and
we're trying to represent how much noise
there is the various different
frequencies at which like a row operates
so you can see the bulk of the
sensitivity this is 100 Earth is between
a few hundred Earth's and the detector
really operates between safer
Hertz and a killer it's above and below
that the sensitivity shoots up so it's
not as good what this early here means
is the range of sensitivity that was
expected for advanced like a first
observing run the lower this curve is
the better it is the more sensitive the
detector and the distance here is 40 yes
when you say frequency of no this is the
frequency of the actual signal that you
expect to detect yes yes sorry for that
confusion yes so you're using a laser
but you're really timing photons and so
you're sensitive to the frequency of
whatever chirp of gravitational waves is
coming out and that's what I'm plotting
there yes distance ranges in megaparsecs
just because so million of parsecs here
and I'm indicating the conversion in
lightyears just for those word I'm
familiar so you can see there's a blue
range and those were expectations the
first observing ground actually reached
the bottom of that range so it was
pretty good that was where the first
binary black hole detections happen mid
here is what happened during the second
observing run and that the green area
there here we actually were more towards
the bottom of that curve okay not quite
as good as expected but still within the
range ultimately the slate curve is
what's going to happen or we're hoping
it's gonna happen in fall 2018 and then
the ultimate goal would be to reach this
this black line here that would be the
nominal advanced lack of sensitivity so
in general the pots that I'm gonna show
you about signals are going to show you
something like strain okay as a function
of frequency from the particular
gravitational wave signal that one is
looking at and so you want that signal
to be above this curve in order to be
detectable the type of signals that I'm
going to focus on because those are the
detections that have to come so far are
merging compact objects as we call them
a pair of
they're a pair of neutron stars mashing
toward each other after spiralling
closer and closer those are what we call
for like a short duration well modeled
signals in the sunset you can't predict
rather accurately the evolution of the
gravitational wave amplitude with time
and its evolution with frequency and
that helps you a lot because considering
all the noise that that this detector
you know are affected from there are
pretty good seismometers track passing
by the detector is kind of knock the
detector and so on so you really have to
dig into the noise the statistics is
largely non-gaussian and when you know
what you expect to see in the data you
can use what is called much filter so
you're much more sensitive but there's a
bunch of other you know possible signals
for longer duration or not so well
modeled that in the future you know
we're looking forward to eventually see
but all of the signals I'm going to talk
about are in this upper coronary year of
short duration and well modeled
waveforms so well advanced LIGO one
here's when we started saying welcome to
the era of gravitational wave
astrophysics and these were the results
of the first observing run two pair of
black holes were pretty confidently
detected and there was another candidate
binary black hole which we were not so
confident about so again it hasn't kind
of gotten the same name as the other so
it's not really hole an event is still
called a candidate but it's a standing
out it's definitely stands out in the
data again let's go back to that u curve
I showed you before so what do this
signal look like so first we called them
gravitational wave fifteen or nine
fourteen because that was detected in
2015 September 14 and that is the
sensitivity of the detector Humphry
limits
now the real one okay it's not all of
these minds and features that you see
are things that are related to
instrumental noise lines and so on and
then what you see drawn here is actually
the track in the frequency domain of The
Associated waveform which you see here
represented in time domain if you like
so you here you have time that is
passing by and that the strain is that
HD amplitude of that wave I told you
about so if you were to see it in time
domain you can see GW 15 or 914 was the
shortest in band and then GW 15 12 26
also pair of buckles but lighter stayed
longer lasted longer in the bandwidth
and so this is if you wanted to plot
them in the strain versus frequency
plane so that's GW 15 or 914 and then
the least massive of the two of the of
the to secure detection if you like of
binary black holes there this is just to
give you an idea that based on when the
signal the frequency at which the signal
and or if you like how long the signal
stays in band can give you an idea of
how massive the objects that are merging
are yes right so one of these was still
a candidate yes that one
seems way as well about the noise yes
yes it is and so the thing is that when
you're measuring it if you're showing it
in this way you know it it's not quite
telling you if you like how long the
tails in the distribution of that noise
is so the noise is largely known
Gaussian okay so SNR very high you need
to kind of relate that to what this is
the false alarm probability for that
high acinar because you can have highest
nor glitches so I'll show you that in a
couple of slides but if you like this
was if you were to you know translate
that signal-to-noise ratio for slam
probability this was something like
order of 2.1 sigma equivalent
these waves are mean we should have the
opposite of what you would expect rather
than an attack followed by a decay there
you know an oscillation and then an
abrupt stop yeah so what's going on is
in marching those two neutron stars
they're spiraling toward each other so
they're dancing and dancing and that's
the first part of the wave and then all
of a sudden they go boom they merge and
that's where you see that hard spike and
then it stops in the band so it starts
less violent and it ends yes it stops in
the band does that mean it it stops
physically or it stops in in a region in
which you can record so what could be
going on you just can't record it in
some other region right so it's changing
very drastically what you're seeing so
it goes from an Inspiral to something
very dynamic which looks very different
so it's a ring down of a final black
hole at that point so you're seeing the
merger yes this is a very good question
but what type of waves are these
longitudinal those are transverse yes
there's no polarization oh the
polarization whoa there is sources vary
here so given that the sources have
orientation yes so the polarization you
know to the first L equal m equal to
mode which is the lowest least order if
you like Louis older if you like the
polarization you're actually going to be
more sensitive to depends on your
organization with respect to the two
binaries that is taken into account yes
so the response of the detectors take
that into account type of source yes so
well you know that it's an Inspiral okay
and then what you can tell is really
well there's a degeneracy between
distance and inclination so if you like
by studying the response how more of a
phosphorylation you got with respect to
the cross correlation you can infer
something about the orientation keeping
in mind that there's a large correlation
with the distance and so in cases in
which you actually see on
from magnetic signature that signature
gives you distance and that's why that's
so important because that way you remove
one uncertainty and then you can
constrain the inclination veins the
molar ization information so so
committee expecting the future
instruments that can measure the
polarization directly yeah well okay to
some extent were already doing we can
already say how much of pus and crust
there was maybe the way I would say that
is if we have more of DCM polyps we can
certainly get more information about the
paths and cross component so not sure if
that answers the question doesn't heal
that you have several sorry say that you
know Oh more defectors absolutely yeah
yeah absolutely yes so it definitely
helps having more detectors and I'll
show you a clear example and a few in a
few moments for constraining that
polarization yes the the way in which
that can be dramatic it's better
explained with the neutron star merger
yes just so I understand it every every
of these binary black hole collapses
still the source still produces both
polarization is it's neither detection
sensitivity right though the actual
source does produce both modes right
right so in nearly equal let me call to
approximation yes now you can you can
infer different things about various
sources or arrive to more exotic forms
of GR and so on which would influence
the polarization but in general for a
certain part of polar order you can tell
okay so if the system is on axis based
on how the inclination angle is you can
predict that and then using the response
of the detector to the paths and cross
modes you can figure out what amplitude
do you expect in the to those actual
claws on the right those are data or the
numerical
no no these are the templates they're
way too beautiful yes yes okay oh the
other thing I wanted to point out is if
you look at this number this is the
units of 10 to the minus 21 that number
I originally pointed out and UW 1509 14
at peak reaches that so this was a
pretty massive order of 30 solar masses
pair of backhoe and so it was
beautifully detected in the data here's
a bunch of math that I don't want to
spend too much time about but this is
there has been already a several
questions but in practice what are you
sensitive to when you're measuring
gravitational waves well to lower order
the dominating factor is what we call
the chip mass so it's a combination of
the masses of the masses of the two
objects here labeled M one and M two and
that shared mass you kind of related all
you care about in this right hand side
here is F and F dot that's the frequency
content so that frequency evolution I
showed you how the frequency evolved z'
over time it's giving your constrain on
the chirp mass of the system if you are
able to have system massive enough that
the merger happens in band exactly like
I said here so the merger happens in the
band where if you like over there where
the detector is sensitive then you can
get constraints some additional
constraint on the total mass of the
system because that to ring down that I
told you so these two two compact
objects match each other each other
there's a final Barco form which is
initially not symmetric so it rings down
gravitational waves associated to that
information if you're sensitive to that
then that helps you constrain the total
mass as well so you can't disentangle
the values of the two masses alone and
so the degeneracies or the kind of
constraints that you get looks something
like this here is in terms of their
component masses and one the more
massive one and M two and these are the
free events I showed you so for the
lower mass events you
see they follow that pattern over there
and that is basically a distribution of
constant chirp mass for the more massive
of the free GW 15 or 914 you saw that
merger happening in the part of the
detector sensitivity which is a kind of
low so you could see better the merger
and that's why the constraint kind of
follows more of a shape in total mass
and here are the distances again here is
the type of this disk irv gives you the
kind of errors okay that could be
affected that your data could be
affected by and there they can be rather
large again in the absence of
electromagnetic hunter bar so that kind
of is the one of the key motivations for
going after any other signal
accompanying this gravitational wave
events there are some challenges in the
data and one thing I mentioned is that
again the distribution of the noise is
largely long Gaussian so here's an
example from Hanford and Livingston
detectors that's the signal-to-noise
ratio and that's the trigger rate and
the various colored histograms are just
showing you the black one in particular
just shows you what will be all of the
noise and then the collaboration goes
through a series of checks what we call
vetoes to veto all the spurious event
and so on so that you're in the end your
distributions are much cleaner so you're
able to kill a lot of that high
signal-to-noise events in the tail but
that's why we say the distribution of
the noise is largely non Gaussian so
again when you speak about a scenario
you always need to be a little careful
of what does it mean and there in this
two plots I'm showing you the event 15
or 914 the pair of massive black holes
that's frequency versus time your
millisecond is just a different way of
showing you the time frequency evolution
the color coding here you can think
about it as power okay
so you can see that the during day in
spiral phases trip so the frequency is
going up as a function of time
and these are spectrograms of a real
event here is something that can happen
in the data which is called a glitch so
a short instrumental noise our artifact
and so that is why the data analysis is
the in general challenging and takes a
lot of effort and people to go through
all these data with various expertise or
figuring out where the various glitches
can come from confused when you say
signal-to-noise ratio when you do signal
processing noise ratio is huge and
that's a fantastic thing yes but this is
noise right so the thing is that when
you're looking at the data from these
detectors you can they're very sensitive
to sis make for example type of noise
and so on so it's a truck going by and
so on so you can easily have high you
know a long tail of high signal-to-noise
ratio events which are support use okay
yes so the problem is what you're
calling signal and what you're calling
noise is yeah but in when you look at
your time data series you don't know so
all you know is about the events is okay
there's an event with a certain SNR and
so what you need to figure out is there
any real event if you like okay so sorry
it's not it's not you know the true
signal is your exact link for it
yes junk to noise ratio and that's yes
so in the end you want to cut those
deals that's a message that I was trying
to get through your problem is that your
jump is high ascend are yes that's a
problem that the statistics is Island
and Gaussian so you get large SNR to
I have you know xnr above 10 I think oh
that's fantastic I said girl yes usually
that's an art of like you know negative
5 DB negative 40 DB is terrible but ok
but right the issue is it's not really
it's not signal of interest exactly yes
it's a tale of Sporus noise yes what
happens with a black hole black hole
merger in our Milky Way are you gonna
throw that away because the signal team
is too much the meters are there I'm
going to make sure that the you know you
kill what you know is instrumental ok so
then another challenge
apart from this that I've shown you
already is the fact that you can think
about gravitational wave detectors as
really a pair of years rather than a
pair of eyes and we still want to use
them to do astronomy so in other words
the sensitivity to various sky location
of gravitational wave detector you can
imagine the two l-shaped arms being here
this peanut shape shows you where from
the sky that the doctor would be
sensitive to okay and you can see that
there's a few points where the detector
is blind lying on the plane of the
detector but overall it's a pretty much
all sky detector and the first thing you
think is oh well that's great because no
matter where the source going off
there's only a few blind spots and so I
should be able to see it and it is true
but it's not as useful when you're
trying to actually localize the source
because you would like to say alright
the source happened from a certain patch
of the sky that potentially other
optical or electromagnetic telescope can
go and follow so rather than saying is
more or less or over the sky you would
want to be a little bit more precise
than that and that's why you need a
network of detectors that's where really
having more than one detector helps you
can think about having multiple
detectors here is Hanford Livingston and
Virgo as doing triangulation between
arrival times of the gravitational wave
signal to the very
detectors to try to localize them in the
sky so if you have only a pair of
detector for example hum furred and
Livingstone in this example what you can
do is localize based on the time delay
the source on a ring on the sky so if
you repeat this with three detectors and
come and consider all the possible pairs
then you see that the signal from the
intersection of these different circles
in the sky is much better localized so
in general it will not be localized to
mirror patches in the sky this is if you
only consider timing information if you
include amplitude information and so the
response of the various detectors to the
plots and cross polarization considering
that in general the earth is curved so
the detectors won't be lying exactly in
a plane then you can further reduce
distant certainty but in general for the
free binary black holes that I showed
you this bananas okay here on the sky
represent their localization area so the
problem was then that Virgo was not
taking data and so we had only two
detectors and the sky localizations were
huge here the number so best thing was
230 square degrees which is pretty large
way too large to follow that up in
electromagnetic with electromagnetic
telescopes in an efficient or systematic
way if you think about eventually the
rate of this events will become you know
tens of hundreds per year so in spite of
the challenge like in Virgo did set up a
program for using the network of
detectors so this little scheme here is
also including future detectors
potentially there's going to be a legal
India Kagura is under construction and
geo 600 is a smaller detector which is
has actually been taking data but in
general if you have a network of
gravitational wave detectors they send
you the triggers in principle you
analyze your data in first sky position
just using the principle mostly mostly
triangulation of the showed you before
you have to estimate your background to
make sure what's significant is what's
not so eventually
we'll be able to select some candidates
event and after some validation in that
equality etc the idea was let's send
that information out to party
electromagnetic up strong strana MERS in
various bands of the spectrum so that
you can potentially find a counterpart
so this went on for already for the
binary neutron star events what is the
real goal of an iam follow-up program is
well you want to make sure that you can
identify gravitational wave events as
quickly as possible so that you don't
miss the opportunity of following them
up as they might be transient in the
electromagnetic band and for this the
way in which this program was set up is
initially like a in Virgo setup
memorandum of understanding with various
telescopes and groups astronomers and
sent GCN what we call GCM notices or
circulars or if you like alerts only to
this group of partners astronomers and
the idea was to allow for a quick
coloration between transient surveys or
candidates or triggered follow-up
observations for parameter delay
counterparts in the electromagnetic band
now what was the goal well for sure pick
up you know interesting events from the
gravitational wave side and from the
electromagnetic side try to prioritize
follow-up resources again those sky maps
are pretty big or were pretty big for
those events so there has to be some
prior is Asian that's why the
partnership of multiple groups and then
the potential is you may capture
counterpart that might have otherwise
been missed or detect only later the key
goal is measure a distance so
electromagnetic counterparts can give
you location in a house galaxy and so
allow you to remove the generous e with
one of the parameters you have when
you're modeling the gravitational wave
form and a lot of astronomical context
of course of what might have been the
progenitor of the gravitational wave
signal in general the main objective was
to allow as much as possible this the
birth of multi man
under astronomy so looking not just that
the gravitational waves but adds photons
and light as counterpart to to the event
this has happened in spite of the large
bananas in the sky so 15 or 914 that
first binary black hole that I showed
you was accompanied by a really great
effort really huge effort in trying to
find light from this event at of
wavelengths now it was the first
detection so if you focus a little bit
on this graph so this is a t minus T
mergers so is measuring time since
merger of those pair of black holes and
this is one day that's ten days at a
hundred days up here is what the like a
Virgo collaboration did so there wasn't
the initial gravitational wave recovery
of the signal the first notice sent you
see you notice here it's after a day and
then updated circulars to tell everybody
this is a binary black hole event again
here we are beyond ten days and then the
final scan sky up here we are beyond a
hundred days so this is real time but
not so too much real time yet it was the
first event so things proceeded slowly
er than they actually did with the
latest detection and you can see x-rays
and high-energy missions going after at
least part of the sky map here is
optical in UV and that's radio
wavelength and there's some images again
that same banana in the sky I showed you
the localization area in black and the
green and pink are trying to show you
what those various electromagnetic
telescopes try doing tiling the sky and
search for a counterpart where that goes
out the sky map that sent out is that
merely a composite of square degrees or
there's some waiting of it yes it's it's
giving for each pixel a probability of
an enclosed probability that the signal
comes from there yes so the the areas of
by the way I was mentioning here those
are ninety percent and close probability
so you add up from each pixels until you
arrive to that ninety percent total yes
contacts right right okay so there was
no electromagnetic counterpart 2gw
fifteen or nine fourteen in the interest
of time I'll I'll I'll go fast here but
there was a potential candidate so there
was no security denta fication of any
electromagnetic counterpart although the
Fermi GBM detected a potential gamma-ray
signal here is showing relative times at
second with respect to the gravitational
wave event versus Fox this has been
controversial because it wasn't an
observed by other telescopes and you
know it hasn't been confirmed but
certainly with many more detections if
there is this type of counterpart at
some point we should be able to
constrain it that's all say for now let
me go quickly to then what happened
during observing run - and here is where
towards the end virgo joins so we really
have the big impact of now a being a
fair detector and not made a whole lot
of difference
this was the run that as I told you has
had improved since the DVD this distance
range tells you how far away binary
neutron stars could be observed that 60
mega parsec there gives you roughly the
vertical sensitivity so the European
deduct on detector was slightly less
sensitive but it made a whole lot of
difference because of the improved
localization areas so overall with first
observing and run and second one here's
the population of binary black hole
events that LIGO in Virgo detected so
now we have a bunch of
zoo if you like a several if you like
events in the zoo of possible masses
these are solar masses and the the big
GW 15 and 914 the massive one I showed
you I talked quite a bit about is up
here there's a several lower massive
event this was one happened in in the
second observing run there's a second of
observing run as well so several events
also during the observing run also
binary black holes but what was cool
probably the most important ones was the
binary black hole happened in August
because that was the first tribal
coincidence here again you're looking at
those spectrogram times versus frequency
and that's the power so you can see how
it was observed by the three detectors
and the key point to take home is the
localization went to from over a
thousand square degrees which you could
have just using the two LIGO detectors
sure was shrunk down to sixty square
degrees when you considered Vigo avoid
in Virgo it was less significant than
another detectors again due to the
little worse sensitivity so this was a
big deal of all I have to say that this
poorer binary buckle was almost kind of
forgotten by everyone because a free
three days after there was an ever
bigger there was an even bigger event in
the sense of how remarkable it was and
it was the localization of the first
binary neutron star merger so our role
here is again a sky map of the various
events observed by Lago in Virgo during
the first and second observing runs
that's the trifle detection of that
binary black hole has told you about you
can see how much the error area shrunk
by using a first detector and if you
stare closely at this image there's
another event GW 1708 17 which has a
comparable small error area and this was
the first binary neutron star merger
detected by the network so I'll spend a
bit of time in this
event here are again those
time-frequency trucks as they looked for
the binary neutron star merger in LIGO
Hanford Livingston and Virgo you see
anything in Virgo is no in fact there
isn't anything in Virgo but that turned
out to be pretty important so what
happened is Virgo had the sensitivity to
see that event but that event happened
to happen in a region of the sky where
the detector was blind and so the fact
that if fall into one of these blind
spot allowed us to eliminate one of
these two mirror remember there's two
patches in the sky when you use free
detectors to localize them there's a
mirror image of one another so one of
the ones was thrown out because of that
so that allowed a much better
localization I mentioned challenges
while there was a big challenge in this
case also you can see that time
frequency track of the signal in the
LIGO hum for like a Livingston detector
and that's a huge glitch right in
between when the signal is happening so
this is one of those noisy events that
are due to instrumental artifacts which
we have to cut out in order to you know
do the proper sky map and so on so let
me go here because of that large glitch
here is the timeline of GW 1708 17 and
you can see we're moving more towards
our real-time detection of these
triggers and distribution of the alert
so the event time in UTC was around here
and you can sort of look okay exactly
how long did it take before the arrival
in virgo collaboration sent out the
alert and so before with DW with the
binary black hole event i showed you it
took quite a long time as we discussed
here the time was less than an hour
indian to get that first that first DC
and notice out and you can see
immediately after there was a report on
behalf of the fermi GBM team regarding
the coincidence with this first binary
neutron star merger
with a gamma-ray signal and now pause
here because it wasn't just the first
binary neutron star detected by three
detectors like in Virgo there was also a
coincident gamma-ray signal something
really astonishing because what is what
people had been searching for for a
really long time and to have that first
binary neutron star detected already
with a neon counterpart was a pretty big
deal so here's the Fermi GBM light
produces gamma rays as a function of
time that's the time frequency track
again of the binary neutron star merger
and you can see there's a spike in gamma
rays about two seconds after the event
the idea is is that there's this two
compact object two neutron star they're
spiraling toward each other they merge
so that forms that track and then what's
left after is likely a black hole with
an accretion disk that launches a jet
and that is what you see as that gamma
ray signal about two seconds after so
this was pretty remarkable to have not
just the first binary neutron star
merger but also the first coincidence
with a gamma-ray burst so going forward
I would say the big deal about the
localization is better illustrated here
so here's the error box that would have
come just from seeing the gamma rays
from that event this patches here the
long and elongated the bananas here are
the localization if you just use the two
LIGO detectors and then if you use Virgo
that's where the patch of the sky the
ultimate patch of the sky falls so you
can see they're really reduced error
area that was about 30 square degrees
when you use the free detectors and the
thing I wanna stress is the free
detectors will I go and Virgo in the end
provided a much smaller localization
than one would have had just by seeing
in gamma rays that event
the aspect of real-time decision here is
illustrated by the massive I think an
really amazing follow-up effort was put
together by the community to follow this
in x-rays UV optical infrared up to down
in the radio it's a busy plot so
probably you can't read very well here
but now all these segments represent you
know observations at various wavelength
and when they started and remember in
the part i showed you about the binary
black hole we had a day ten days a
hundred days well here the the latest
amount of time that elapsed between the
trigger the gravitational wave trigger
and all of these observation this is a
scale of ten days so this was an
incredibly massive effort that localized
the binary neutron star merger to that
host galaxy that little dot over there
was the optical counterpart months is
gonna tell you i guess more about this
and how a massive effort like this can
actually happen yes is there any story
about the people that got bumped to yes
i think there's lots of painful stories
i would say i won't get into that let me
stick to the beautiful aspect of it i do
have a great story a positive one okay
about this that I'll share the at the
break yes so there's lots of stories
behind this but the key messages the
gamma rays got detected basically
immediately with that coincidence there
were there was a new video an optical
flash discovered after that a signature
of what we call the killer nova and then
the radio followed a couple of weeks
after we had to be patient to detect
that but it was a beautiful effort and
here's where it links to this real-time
optical detection effort that has been
have been discussed since this morning
you could think about this of what would
happen in the LSTs
ear and so on we were getting into the
details of the
part here is the summary of where we are
right now with Lego and Virgo these are
all in blue the binary black hole
systems that have been detected in
purple what we knew before about binary
black holes from x-ray observations and
then here towards the lower masses again
these are solar masses the neutron stars
and that's the of that we know about and
that's a lag of your go neutron star
here which probably ended up into
forming a black hole although that's
question mark still and that's where in
the future we could do a lot more
statistics of understanding what happens
after two neutron stars merge the future
so here's what we are this is ears this
is like a Virgo and potentially Cara
coming up that is under construction
right now so I told you about oo 1 and O
2 the 1st and 2nd observing run up
coming towards the fall of 2018 will be
the 3rd observing run and so you can
compare distance reaches or the
improvement sensitivity I think it's
safe to assume that the detectors would
reach the lowest estimated sensitivity
there so you can compare with the
improvement of a2 and the key thing will
be that because of those detection 's
we're gonna enter into the era of public
alerts so I show I discussed about how
like a miracle had set up this kind of
private network partners astronomers so
that they could follow up in the
electromagnetic bond those high
significant alerts now are going to go
public so they can be followed up by the
larger community and in terms of rates
this table is a little bit busy it's
showing you for the lag of you're going
kagura detectors the expected distance
ranges but what you want to mostly focus
on is as you know your distance reach
and we have from those binary neutron
star in whenever you block or detection
now some constraints on the rate you can
ask yourself okay how common are these
detection is going to be in the upcoming
runs so the answer is potentially ten or
a few up to ten binary neutron stars in
the offeree run not all of these are
going to be try pole detection and for
the for the binary neutron sorry that's
an error that should be for the binary
black holes the numbers are much higher
so there you're looking at into a
hundred or a thousand per year once we
need to nominal sensitivity the binary
black hole rate they are very events but
you can see them because they're more
massive much larger distances so you
reach the Giga parsec range rather than
the few hundred megaparsecs and in the
public alerts era so what exactly does
it mean for public alert well there's
gonna be meetings discussing about this
this upcoming pretty soon in March but
the basic promise that like a miracle
made are that after the those few
detections they the events that are
gonna go public so the alerts are going
to go public are going to report about
the most significant events so that
means false alarm rate of less than one
per a hundred years and then there is
the possibility that like a miracle will
still want to you know set up ammo use
or a partnership with astronomers that
might be interested in following up less
significant events for carrying out a
specific search or science objective so
it's not clear yet how many part and the
stories we'll want to do is that how
lose will their threshold for sharing
this additional triggers will be but
this is all upcoming for discussion and
a last note on speed versus quality in
this real-time alerts based on what I
showed you with the latest event the
binary neutron star merger we can
summarize by saying it can be pretty
fast to for like a member go to sent out
first analysis and sky map for
collecting binary events so roughly
about a minute since the experience we
have
there is a latency still that is has
been in during a 102 of tons of minutes
even for the binary neutron star merger
and that is really dominated by human
checks I showed you in the case of the
binary neutron star merger there was
this huge glitch light in the middle of
the track so there is still some
increased time delays because of that
there is some envisioning law of sending
preliminary alerts without this step
here so we've got this human vetting now
there's the points being discussed there
is okay
perhaps we could clearly label those but
or is everyone gonna be ready to you
know screen those preliminary alerts and
most of all take note about potential
retraction notices and so on so again
these are topics that are going to be
discussed in there very soon and in the
upcoming months before the fall 2018
observing run starts and I just want to
summarize everything I've said by saying
like and video have made indeed their
first gravitational wave detection x'
here's the like of checklist
binary black holes have been detected
binary neutron star have been detected
binary neutron stars with an even
counterpart have been detected this came
all with one single event that was me
that's what made it so amazing but
there's a bunch of things here in the
list that have not been detected that
we're looking forward to first thing
probably a binary a black hole neutron
star merger but also those other type of
sources such as exposing massive star
supernova or continuous gravitational
waves from stable neutron stars
potentially a stochastic background from
binary black holes all of these are
stuff we're paying attention to which
there's potential for new data analysis
techniques as well so the sensitivity
should improve for free so we can expect
binary neutron stars and binary black
holes detections reasonably and
the era of gravitational wave astronomy
has really started obviously we don't
quite know whether that
counterpart that we would detected is
typical that's the next big question
that we want to answer but at least we
know we have at least one event now
which is again much better than when I
started in this field so I'll close it
there so we had time for a few questions
yes so let me give you a very honest
answer so in order to reach 100 mega
parsec with something which is related
to the explosion of a massive star you
have to think of something really
dramatic so the most optimistic models
for this kind of massive star explosions
are related to long gamma ray bursts so
those very massive stars that launch a
jet and potentially create instabilities
in the accretion disk so they've been
like okay you got two blobs of the order
of mass of a neutron star and then they
merge and you can get something out of a
supernova so these are the most exotic
ones and I will say we can certainly
hope to exclude those at least but then
of course if you want to have a more
ordinary supernova explosion then
probably on our galaxy is the better bet
for having a detection so there's huge
uncertainties there's at least I would
say with the improved sensitivity and
longer time scale for running we can
start at least throwing away a bunch of
theoretical models so curious about the
difference between the LS and LS T
strategy because in one case you sort of
outsource all the analysis a we don't
take responsibility for this thing
do with this data well in this case
you're more careful and you mentioned
yet is the Astronomy community prepared
so what's the cost for the community if
you give them less refined data which
might contain faith yeah so far what I
can say is we had zero events and I in
the gravitational waves and we got the
first few detections so we we were so
far in a very different regime that
we've Alice STR gonna have a ton of
stuff out there and we had very few so
the decision was to you know send out be
careful about sending out because we've
never seen anything like that are really
venting gravitational waves so you want
to be careful about making big claims
now how much one can release now that
being very careful and so for example
sharing potentially still with them or
your lower threshold events it's
something that is being discussed I
would say the highest rate that you can
expect our binary black hole mergers
sorry for that type of there and so the
question is for example do astronomers
want to follow up potentially hundreds
of events that potentially have no
electromagnetic counterpart and I guess
months you also in the next stock will
probably answer how much does that cost
to the community or in terms of effort
at least a bit better but you know it's
a trade-off between what you want to
achieve so my guess is those binary
neutron stars are the few events that
we're still going to get still few in
all free are gonna be the ones where
everyone is probably going to want to
invest and then when we reach that
regime where there's many more events
then some selection has to be decided
there to say okay I only go after this
events if you're thinking of using
expensive follow-up resources like
Chandra or the Very Large Array and so
on
in a distributed observation arrangement
situation one of these if you're trying
to detect coincidence then of course at
a common time basis necessary are there
any issues with respect to propagating
time to time base or for the
gravitational survey across that's an
excellent question so let me go back to
this yes little cartoon here so we can
look for example of that two-second
delay so what's the expectation in
general you expect for at least compact
binaries that you would see the
gravitational wave signal first and then
some electromagnetic foreigner part
should follow a different time scale you
would expect it yes depending on what
frequencies were looking at so this time
particular time delay here which is
about two seconds was coming from the
idea that there was something like this
coming on so a binary neutron star
merger launching a jet and that signal
in high energy will reach you basically
right away if the jet was pointed at you
after the murder but the problem or the
beauty I would say of this event was
that that jet wasn't actually pointed
straight at us we think so that
determined originally you probably a two
second delay if you think about it as
being associated with what we call a
cocoon so some slower material around
that jet that you're actually observing
in x-rays up to the point where you push
it in radio so lower and lower
wavelengths and then we have to wait
actually two weeks for that jet to
eventually reach our eyes spread and
reach our eyes so there is there are
some ideas about the time correlation so
how fast do you need to go in the short
answer is the highest frequency the
faster you want to go after the
gravitational wave event probably but we
haven't quite mapped you know the zoo of
possibilities depending on what what is
contributing to the emission in the
electromagnetic pond the jet slower
stuff around it even slower Newton rich
debris and so on so I would say there
are
yes so so thinking about the more
general case the question might be with
respect to the alerting system the data
schema for the alerts how do you include
a reference to a time base that's
recoverable oh so what do you mean time
there's time being that is recoverable
I'm not quite sure I'm understanding
your question an indication of a clock
source yes for subsequent observations
to reference so we can refer all these
yeah their triggers you got is you can
refer them in GPS time right and then
I'm not sure if I'm I'm catching Europe
your question you always use the final
signal the merger part after part as
time zero and so you refer to the you
know spiraling in as negative and then
anything after that is positive that's
the way they they do it and then of
course depending upon the model then it
trickles out later depending what
frequency let's say GPS time or some
kind of global yes yes yes and I do have
to say no that I I think of what Peter
said there is a possibility that you
actually don't see the merger time in
your bond so right if the system is very
low masses then you might not see that
merger so in principle this part in
spiral goes on and you might have some
time delay between you know what your
end of the signal is is what you see in
band and what you see in exactly yes so
there might be that uncertainty indeed
in there to take into account yes so I
have a question on doing this the other
way around
yeah which is that surveys are coming
online like CTF yes in which they will
be much more sensitive
binary neutron star mergers than leg
yes so what about diggie opposite yes
yeah back into the data yes she find
events so luckily and Twitter you know
this by me stressing you about
candidates so we've done that exercise
before so luckily that exercise has been
done actually more for more ears than
the opposite one of LIGO sending alerts
so this is what LIGO calls triggered
searches so it's the opposite way you
take triggers from whatever optical
service or gamma-ray burster signal that
comes out there and you go look into
your data in the gravitational wave data
to see if there's anything significant
the good thing is that gravitational
wave data are all archived so you know
you can use whatever if you like survey
triggers to go back and check into your
data
now obviously the faster you do that the
better the chances of catching other
counterparts for example if you wanted
to do follow-up but this exercise I
would say certainly Palmer transient
factory was among the service that
pioneered and LIGO has been doing it for
for a long time in coincident with Swift
and Fermi triggers so that is certainly
gonna continue I would say then how
would you depending on what the survey
is doing whether the survey has public
triggers or not you might consider maybe
discussing with LIGO in terms of MoU or
so on yes absolutely you know how much
you can nobody can narrow the explosion
time right I mean yes so if you only
know exposing them to a day that's not
being good enough for you guys right it
depends on how nodes in general they
supernova triggers with like a day or a
week inserted he makes that very hard if
you combine it with unknown signal shape
now if it's an in spiral a distance yes
we will have a very good localization
yes so that should help us handle some
of the time uncertainty yes and also
knowledge if you are have you
reasonable expectation that it might be
a chirp a compact binary merge arranges
a supernova where we don't know what the
signal looks like I would expect that to
also influence the day good enough I
mean what do you need to be done your
noise if you know perfect positions
about second perfect redshift you say it
is a compact binary merger then what
delta-t uncertainty is so the best alpha
t that has been used this forger be
triggers which is a few seconds or a
minute or a couple of minutes around
that trigger for those events but again
it depends on you know what you're
searching for so I would expect a pretty
it's not easy but you know it can be
handled because it is being handled with
supernova triggers so obviously you
can't expect as much than three videos
when you have a two minutes or a few
seconds time doing the other questions
okay
let's thank our yeah
[Applause]